uh this is another one of those many
worlds videos where i have my phone
dangling over my whiteboard i made some
videos a while back about how i really
like the mini world's interpretation and
how i think it solves a lot of the
problems with regular quantum mechanics
but i have to admit there's always been
one part of the many worlds theory that
i didn't understand and i felt like was
probably the biggest source of uh
potential issues with the theory so i've
been thinking about that issue for a few
months and this is the fifth time that
i've tried to record this video but i
think i finally got it straight in my
head the thing i'm going to be talking
about is probability in the many worlds
theory the reason why that's such a
tricky topic is because the many worlds
theory just doesn't seem like it should
have probability in it at all like
there's no uncertainty when you do a
measurement usually in quantum mechanics
if something is a superposition of two
different possibilities let's say a and
b that means that it's kind of doing
both of them at the same time and if you
went to measure it would collapse to
just doing one or the other with some
probability but in the many worlds
theory that's just not how it works
instead if you try and measure whether
it's a or b
there will be one version of yourself
who sees the outcome a and a completely
separate version of yourself who sees
the outcome b and those are essentially
different worlds there is no randomness
it almost doesn't make sense to talk
about what is the probability of a
happening it definitely happens but i
think that it is actually really
important to bring probability back into
many worlds and that's because let's say
that you are going to do an experiment
in the lab
and regular quantum mechanics would tell
you that
one third of the time you should expect
to see a and two-thirds of the time you
should expect to see b
you get the experience when you do that
experiment of getting a random outcome
and that a third of the time you get a
that is an observable part of the
quantum theory and so how is many worlds
going to reproduce that kind of
randomness that's the question for
today's video the most popular way to
resolve this issue is to kind of forego
uncertainty altogether and instead
define the probabilities in terms of
like uh betting and things like that
while i think that that's all very
elegant i think that i would prefer a
understanding of probability that is a
little bit closer to my intuitive
understanding of probability and so
that's why in this video i'm going to
talk about a more straightforward way to
bring uncertainty into the many worlds
theory and how that leads to the
probabilities that you would expect from
quantum mechanics but before i talk
about what i think is the right answer
i'd like to first talk about what i
think is not the right answer even
though it is very appealing and that is
where if you want to find the
probability of a you just count the
number of worlds where a happens over
the total number of worlds that there
are and that is your probability of a
that seems like it would be a great
solution but unfortunately it's just not
we're going to see in the following
example that if you try and assign
probabilities that way that you run into
inconsistencies where you try and find
out the probability by doing the
measurement one way and you get a
certain answer and then you try and find
out the probability by doing the
measurement a different way and you get
a different answer that theory just
can't work um and then we'll go on to
how to fix it
imagine i have something like an
electron and that electron could be
in one of
three possible energy levels you could
imagine this as like energy levels
inside of an atom or something like that
now classically if we had a situation
like this then the electron would be
doing one of those three but in quantum
mechanics there is the possibility of a
superposition what that means is the
electron will be in some sense doing all
three of those things at the same time
but then let's say that i want to go and
measure the electrons energy
what is going to be now the probability
of getting for example a it seems like
all three of them should just be a third
because there are three worlds and why
not assume that they're all equally
likely and so the probabilities should
all be a third but we're gonna see that
that can't be right all the time let's
say that instead of just doing this a b
c measurement you decide to do a
slightly more complicated measurement
and this is the measurement of whether
the state is a or whether it's x
x means an energy higher than a so in
this case that would be b or c this is a
perfectly valid measurement to do so
you're just trying to figure out is the
energy a or is it higher than a and that
is allowed in quantum mechanics so since
there are two outcomes our rule tells us
that the probabilities of both of them
ought to be a half but we don't have to
stop there if we get the outcome x then
we can do a further measurement to
figure out if the energy was b or
whether it was c there are two outcomes
here as well and so those probabilities
should be a half and a half again
according to our rule that all outcomes
should be equally likely but now you've
reached a contradiction because this
whole thing is just a really convoluted
way of doing that same measurement that
you were going to do the first time
you're just figuring out whether the
energy is a b or c
and so these two ways of measuring the
energy ought to give you the same
results and in regular quantum mechanics
they do but here you can see they don't
according to this tree the probability
of finding the outcome c
is a half times a half
same with b
and probability of a is actually a half
so you can see there's this
inconsistency when you try and figure
out the probabilities by doing branch
counting so that means that the
probability in the many worlds
interpretation can't be to do with just
the number of worlds even though that
seems like it should be it to really
drive that home let's look at an example
where there are just two outcomes and
that means that there are just two
worlds and yet we'll find that in some
sense the probability of one of those
worlds is a lot greater than the
probability of another world let's say
that we have a quantum state like this
so don't worry if you haven't seen this
kind of notation before all it's saying
is that we have some sort of particle
and that particle is red
and blue at the same time in what's
called the quantum superposition but in
some sense it's more blue than it is red
because that number in front of the blue
bit is higher than the number in front
of the red bit and the way that would
manifest itself in regular quantum
mechanics is via what's called the born
rule the born rule just says that if you
were to do a measurement of whether the
particle is red or blue in regular
quantum mechanics it would collapse to
just doing one of those so you would
only see one of those colors and the
probability that it is red would be
equal to a third which is
something you get by taking that number
and taking the modulus squared of it
because that number was smaller that
probability is smaller
but how is this going to work in the
many worlds theory where if you were to
do a measurement of this red and blue
particle then you would see both those
outcomes there would be like two
versions of yourself one who sees red
one who sees blue let's say this is you
and you get one of these particles
that's just a representation of the
particle before you measure it because
it's both blue and red but in some sense
it's more blue than red if you were to
actually do this experiment you wouldn't
see both red and blue instead you would
get the situation where you essentially
split into two one version of you would
see the red outcome and the other would
see the blue so i get rid of this
because that state is now gone by the
way it's a very important fact that you
will only be able to experience one of
the worlds even if you know on a
theoretical level that the other world
exists you won't be able to see any
evidence of them you won't be able to
see both a blue particle and a red
particle you'll only be able to see one
outcome it's a really important feature
of many worlds that this is true that
you can only experience one world and
that's basically what is making this
proof work and so if you want to see the
argument for why that's true i've made a
whole video about it but if you're happy
to accept that then let's keep going
with this proof if we were to think
about this from a branch counting point
of view you can see that there are in
fact only two worlds and so you know the
probability of red ought to be half and
the probability of blue ought to be a
half so how are we going to recover the
one-third and two-thirds what does
probability even mean in the
circumstance where both things happen on
metal level there is no uncertainty in
this experiment because you know that
when you do it you are going to split
into two different people and one is
going to see red and one is going to see
blue but on the level of your experience
there actually is a lot of uncertainty
you see each person can only
see one of those outcomes these two
people even though they are both future
versions of that person are now separate
people they're living separate lives
with separate experiences as evidenced
by this they're seeing different things
and are from now on basically two
different people who cannot interact and
can't see the other world but this
person who is in the present there is
some uncertainty and that uncertainty is
what world am i going to experience in
other words if i went into the lab and i
did this experiment i will see a
particular outcome yes i will know that
there's another version of me who saw
the other outcome but i have seen a
particular outcome i will have gone from
this person to one of those two people
but which one
it's gonna be random and so that i think
is how you should be defining
probability to make this feel a little
bit more concrete let's imagine doing
the same experiment but repeatedly so
what's going to happen is each of these
people after they've done their first
experiment they're going to pick up a
fresh particle in the original state
their old particles are used up so they
need to go and get some fresh ones and
now these people are going to do the
measurement again
now there are four people and these are
the outcomes that each of them have
gotten but we can do the experiment
again
these are their outcomes so how should
we define probability we could say that
the probability of red equals the
expected proportion of red what i mean
by expected proportion
is that if you were to actually go ahead
and do this experiment several times
like we've done here then you are going
to end up being one of these eight
people and you don't know which one of
these people but there are some that are
more typical experiences and some that
are less typical experiences this is
quite an atypical experience whereas
this
is much more typical and so you're going
to find that in contradiction with what
we had assumed about branch counting
earlier these different worlds are not
all equally likely you will have the
experience of getting into some of those
worlds more often than you would for the
others and that's why i've used the word
expected because even though you know
there is actually a version of you who
sees all three reds it's not what you
expect to happen if you were to keep on
doing this number a near infinite number
of times and just keep track of how many
times you saw red versus how many times
you saw blue you should find that about
a third of the time you get red and
two-thirds of the time you get blue
so that's probability okay wait a second
i've defined probability and what i mean
by probability in a way that i feel like
makes sense it's sort of about like how
often you can expect to have the
experience of getting into a particular
world or another one but i haven't
proved why that number should equal a
third or two-thirds in this case that is
actually something that you can prove
and i think it's really nice like
actually very simple proof but i've
decided to put the proof of that born
rule into the next video because
interestingly enough that proof doesn't
just apply to many worlds it also works
equally well in the sort of standard
copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics uh weirdly the proof just
doesn't really care about any of the
details of how you define probability as
long as you have defined something
called probability which is essentially
a function that takes your state and
gives you back a number as long as there
is such a thing and you're searching for
it then there is only one function that
will work and that is the modulus
squared function and that's just because
of consistency we talked about how like
if you were assigning probabilities
according to the branch counting rule
then you run into the problem of
a lack of consistency between different
ways of doing measurements like you can
do the measurement one way and get one
outcome and do the measurement another
way get a different outcome so if we
just enforce that the probability rule
that we want is consistent then there is
only one function that fits that bill
and that is the regular born rule so um
i think that's a really neat proof and
so i've decided to just like separate
that out because i think that people
will be interested in that
whether or not they care about many
words so yeah if you want to see that
it's over there